hi everyone it's Jerry I have a simple
game to share with you from the 2016
Chinese chess League
on the wide end the current women's
world chess champion as of May of 2023
June June and she's playing against
rotung Chu
the play in this game feels almost
effortless and I believe a big reason
for this is the rating gap between these
two it's significant
June's rating is 2568
which puts her nearly 500 points higher
than her opponent
it's these types of games I feel
frequently carry with the day high
instructional value
let's have a look
D4 Knight F6
Bishop G5 the trumpowski attack
now after a few more moves we're going
to see that this starts to feel very
much like a Stonewall attack or even a
Pillsbury attack okay however you slice
it white is
attacking in some way
from here D5 E3
simple looking moves to start right we
could get to this position by
transposition
okay nothing
super special in this early going
securing the center on D4 we have a
fallback Square in the event of C4 now
all right Knight B to D7 F4 so this is
where it starts to
for me at least I start thinking about
oh this is like Stonewall attack this is
maybe Pillsbury attack looking to bring
the queen over here
main point behind F4
secure E5 for the king Knight to drop in
there that's the plan
and as mentioned black doesn't really do
anything
about this plan
makes natural
moves you know there's nothing
significantly wrong with
how black is following up V6 Bishop B7
completing development
but there is better
and I'd like to share what that is
it's not just this isn't just me showing
how white steamrolled black here's how
black could interfere with this simple
plan
and a way to do that is Queen B6 what is
the queen doing she's being a queen
she's functioning in two directions
hitting the unprotected B2 Pawn as well
as x-raying the newly weakened
unprotected E3 Pawn
what's the plan after Queen B6 well it
is to offer a pawn sacrifice to open the
lines on the king's side of the board to
interfere with this bishop being in
Black's house
H6
G5 what's happening night Pond likes to
attack Bishop pons
and this right here is as far as I'm
taking it
E5 do you see the compensation
Big Pawn Center for black a lot of
pressure exerted on D4
Open Line for The Rook
with the Rook on B1 there's also a
question mark over the white King's Head
where is your Safe Haven
there's no hanging left in this game
you could also imagine this position
with this Knight more aggressively
placed
meaning if it was deployed on C6
only
adds to the pressure on D4
okay compensation clear compensation for
the pawn
kicks off Queen B6 H6 G5 is a nice
reaction worth looking into
from here B6 Knight G2 F3 Bishop B7
Knight E5
and this Knight is immediately captured
so this is where black starts to go
wrong with this capture
considered best is castles and then to
next drop the Knight into E4 note the
difference between the two
you can't flip a coin on that and say
let me drop in here first before
castling because this is going to hurt
you
that's that's a problem pin tonight
and if you're thinking you could defend
like that this Knight's gonna have some
fun on C6 Landing a fork
okay
castles and then Knight to E4 is a good
continuation but black takes on E5
no reason for white to know
not follow the general rule of taking
towards the center
Knight D7 if the Knight goes into E4
here that's no good
because white would be able to exchange
Bishops
and then land a check on A4
and black Must Go On castled
Queen D7 will lose the queen to Bishop
B5
so the Knight has to hit the reverse
button goes to D7 dark Square Bishops
are off both sides are now castled
Queen G4
and from here F5 so we're only 10 moves
away from this game being over uh the
big thing that sticks out to me about
this position are the light Square
Bishops uh White has the better Bishop
it's it's functioning along this
diagonal well first we get the capture e
takes F6 Han poisson this guy here is
functioning this one not so much
you could in a way say that it's
functioning to a certain degree if you
drop a piece into the E4 it's indirectly
there supporting a jump into that square
in some cases but yeah it's really a
dummy piece and plenty of lines from
this point on
now
play by white in this game was not uh
Flawless this point right here
there's an issue there's a mistake Queen
G3 is played and this gives black an
opportunity to equalize but
it was not found
so I'll throw this to you as a pop quiz
how would you reply to White's last move
feel free to pause the video
okay an excellent reaction to Queen G3
is E5 and I believe this was maybe the
intention White had
behind Queen G3 it was to watch over
this E5 break
but E5 can still hit
now before I share
the E5 variation let me point out what
is considered best at this stage
it is to go Queen H4
this move actually does stop E5
E5 right now would run into this trick
the Knight cannot take
because the queen would fall
so
Queen G3 E5 can be played in the game
Rook 80 E8 is on board but E5 is the
best move here let's see why
black can get away with that
first let's look at the queen capture
Queen takes E5
Queen takes E5 Pawn takes Queen
this square is now open there's no Queen
guarding that so Knight G4 black will
get the pawn back shortly maybe even
better to go after the pawns with the
Rook
okay the other line is to take with the
pawn straight away
black has this nice maneuver
for whatever the reason this sequence of
moves isn't
um
you know it doesn't come instinctually
to me so this was a uh one little detail
that I took away from this game right
here
one of one of the few details I took
away and this this is the move Knight H5
what's that doing it's kicking the queen
away from defending E5
and next the queen is able to take the
pawn back defend the Knight and even
Target this half dead Pawn
it's even position
so this break was available straight
away
instead black looked to prep it
with Rook a to E8
this allowed white the time to
reposition the Knight now this is not so
easy to get in Black insists on trying
to get that move in with Knight to D7
but now this is on this is vulnerable
the pawn on H7 Knight G5
and black must be very careful uh if you
don't have this guy around to defend
your king side squares your light
squares playing a move like this you
would really be asking for trouble
in the game G6 is played
if you're playing H6 the Knight goes
back and now you have to deal with these
ideas
Queen Bishop battery
for instance if black gets E5 in right
now we can chop away and then play Queen
G6 no good answer to Queen H7
we don't care about dropping a pawn
so
best is
uh well better is G6
and from here Rook takes Rook and the
only way to try and stay in the game now
as black is to recapture with the Rook
um
in the game Knight takes Knight is
played if you're taking with the Rook I
want to at least give you a taste
for how white can follow up from here
I like this idea to try and go after the
night
I'd really like to get this Exchange in
and then swing the Knight into E5 and
it's there to stay for the rest of the
game
great Outpost Square
if black tries to duck that we could
activate the pieces like this still in
all variations this is the dummy piece
this guy is you know active
good versus bad Bishop positions always
tipping in White's favor here within
this structure
okay in this game it's Knight takes rook
and now White's able to get to the open
file the only open file index pivot on
F7 this is completely winning at this
stage
from here Rook to E7
this queen is now a Defender
White's trying to deflect it
deflect the defender from The Rook Queen
goes back
Queen is now functioning like a queen
pressure on the the file still on the
diagonal from here Knight D7 and after
Bishop takes Knight this goes no further
black resigns there's no good answer
both recaptures on D7
are have a good reply to it so let's
have a look at both of them
if you take with the queen first of all
we would have a Checkmate in five
starting with Rook f8 check
King G7 only move
Queen E5 check the Rook would be poison
mating the corner
so the king would have to go here and
then the Rook falls back
looking to get to the H file this is the
best way to prolong mate King has to
move forward
and we'd have check checkmate
so the king gets hunted if
Queen takes Bishop maintenance five if
Queen takes Bishop and if Rook takes
Bishop
white would have this nice continuation
Knight takes E6
hitting the queen if the queen moves
it's going to be mainten 2 kicking off
with Rook f8
for example this one here Rook f8 Queen
takes for a queen takes Queen game over
and if in this position you capture The
Rook white has a nice sequence here you
could take on F7 which sets up a perfect
Fork
and the bishop is Tracked Down
white winds
so it goes no further after this last
move
black simply throws in the towel so
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below
I hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye
foreign thank you